[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
consacrée aujourd'hui à la démocratie
directe en suisse dont nous parlerons
avec l'écrivain et historien olivier
meuwly bonsoir monsieur merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
vous êtes un spécialiste de l'histoire
des idées des partis politiques
également vous êtes l'auteur du livre
troxler inventeur de la suisse moderne
aux éditions un folliot et on ne sait
pas toujours et vous allez nous en parle
et la suisse un fonctionnement politique
très particulier
elle permet à ses citoyens de se
prononcer sur les lois d'en proposer et
même de les faire retirer éventuellement
et ce grâce à l'initiative populaire et
au référendum alors parlez nous de
l'histoire de cette démocratie directe
qui est très envié par les gilet jaune
en france notamment
bonsoir l'histoire de la démocratie
directe en suisse évidemment assez
longue mais les outils actuels qui sont
pratiqués très couramment en suisse
remonte au grosso modo au 19e siècle et
ignace folie théâtre auxerre a été un
des acteurs importants de la mise en
place de ce système dans la première
moitié du 19e siècle dans son canton à
lucerne puis après ses idées aussi
rayonner largement en suisse mais
l'esprit de cette démocratie directe est
en fait beaucoup plus anciens on ne peut
pas établir bien sûr un lien direct
entre les landes remind ces fameux
l'assemblée le populaire qui était calé
pour donner encore dans un canton a garé
sa peine sur l'extérieur mais qui était
fréquemment dans les cantons de suisse
centrale
quand on a gricole cotton bowl le
montagner ni voté à main levée
exactement dix sept îles à cet idéal
évidemment on se rend compte au 19e
siècle qu'il est impossible de le
maintenir et de l'appliquer pour des
grandes collectivités
mais l'esprit de cet idéal car c'est
bien idéal pour ceux qui vont mettre en
oeuvre cette démocratie directe qui
décide que la démocratie représentative
ne suffit pas et qu'il faut la compléter
par un action directe du peuple et bien
cet idéal demeure le modèle symbolique
de la landsgemeinde de conduire
aussi les bons seris deuxième à élaborer
les outils modernes
alors justement ces outils modernes
comment fonctionne-t-il parce qu'il ya
des méthodes de référendum d'initiative
avec des signatures expliquez nous alors
il ya deux outils on confond souvent on
rêvait tout cela à une expression de
référendum d'initiative citoyenne et
populaire en suisse il ya deux outils le
premier qui a été expérimenté dans
divers cantons à partir des années 1830
62 veto puis souvent tu techniques
modernes 1145 et environs de mieux que
d'encre tant de vous ont été pionniers
qui permet d'attaquer des lois votées
par le parlement au rassemblement un
certain nombre de signatures qui est
fixée par la constitution
et bien si c'est le nombre de signatures
est atteint et bien le projet de loi
voté par le parlement est soumis à un
vote du peuple
ensuite cette société aujourd'hui c'est
50 villes ce qui est relativement peu vu
de loi mme après c'est pas si simple
aller les chercher sur le terrain
et puis surtout le but c'est que le nom
d relativement bas parce que si on
estime qu'il y à une opposition à une
loi
eh bien il est juste de l'amex de la
soumettre au verdict populaire
il ne faut pas qu'il y ait une sorte
d'obstacles artificiels lié au nombre de
signatures et ce système a été étendu à
la confédération
après diverses expériences dans les
cantons suisses à londres après 1848
mais la date de 1874 l'autre instrument
qui a aussi été créés sont modernes dans
le canton de vaud est repris peu à peu
par d'autres cantons c'est alors
l'initiative populaire qui permet
d'introduire un nouvel article de la
constitution
il n'a pas au niveau sur une véral il
n'y a pas de loi qui dans le système
qu'il avait décrit de proposer une loi
ça cette technique tout de même la
rédaction d'une loi et le revanche la
proposition d'un article constitutionnel
elle est possible et aujourd'hui il faut
sont 1000 signatures à l'époque qui
avait le moins de suffrages
li na a été acceptée et l'allemande a
été doublée à 50 mètres et redonne sept
cent mille la l'initiative populaire
je t'avais donc d'introduire proposer un
sujet si le monde signature est stable
et bien le parlement propositions le
considérait le gouvernement prend lui
aussi position et le texte soumis au
peuple
ou bien tu es le kent ou bien avec un
contre-projet ce qu'on appelle lors une
autre proposition contre l'histoire
proposée par le monde où le par le
parlement les champs fédéral
les deux chambres est le haut le projet
fédéral une précision que c'était
démocratie directe pourrait à saisir la
patine du système suisse c'est la lire
aussi que le système fédéral n'est ce
pas qui qui était basée sur la proximité
a laissé gouvernements cantonaux dans de
petits états qui se considéraient que ça
s'organise comme tel et le fédéralisme
est liée à tracer kumo avec la
démocratie directe
mais alors justement ce système de
il n'est pas si commun que ça dans quel
pays de ces pratiques est alors dans dix
états américains la californie notamment
avec quelques nuances et pour ce projet
c'est donc pratiquer le colorado je
crois aussi les lots d'ouvrir leurs vols
américains
cela a été rejeté par la cour suprême et
c'est vrai que les américains ont fait
le choix de la date d'un exécutif fort
avec le président ce qui n'est vraiment
pas le cas en suisse autrement bien sûr
chaque pays européen à aujourd'hui a
introduit dans ces institutions
quelques outils de démocratie liens avec
la france connait aussi véranda par les
prix oscillent que parfois ouais voilà
donc tous les pays au monde est au
niveau de la suite on est on est les
seuls à part vous voyez c'est ça c'est
certain qu'à un peu unique
alors justement on parlait de la france
la france il ya pensé bien évidemment au
moment de la révolution française elle
l'a même appliquée localement au moment
de la commune et mais on peut pas
l'appliquer de manière générale bien que
les gilets jaunes et soumis cette idée
les revendique et pourquoi on ne peut
pas vous n'y croyez pas à cette
démocratie directe en france
il est clair que en effet
condorcet par exemple le dernier pas de
visa des lumières sous française a
élaboré un système très sophistiqué les
de démocratie directe de référendum
techniquement assez difficile à mettre
en pratique nous avait été discutée a
été repris par la constitution
montagnards mais évidemment pas mis en
pratique on connaît les événements de
cette époque
donc c'était les mêmes lundi les
français donc même une annonce assez
simple son mariage en suisse donc les
divers nautique un peu de la
landsgemeinde médiévale elle et les
idées rationnelle des luminaires tels
que conversait les a proposées dans ce
mariage en suisse donc je pense que le
système est tout à fait reproductible à
peu près partout au monde
le point délicat c'est que même gérer la
tradition et l'histoire que j'ai dit
brilleront répondre à votre question
précédente et les suisses se sont pas
levés en jour de part et d'autre de la
sarine l'est de la rivière qui sépare en
gros les lions françaises et allemandes
elles sont dit ça y est on va inventer
un testing et que c'est super sympa
c'est une mon histoire c'est une autre
histoire qui commence alors à part ces
institutions médiévale qui ont débouché
sur des fois des combats symboliques ou
non de cette démocratie là vers des
prisons xviie siècle et puis les
oligarchies et quand on est patricia
incorporation dans certains cantons
villes et bien avait pas désuni pas il
m'a fallu des mois de négociations avec
la population qui est assez intéressant
pour pour l'époque matériels
heureusement l'histoire une longue
tradition et puis une histoire qui n'est
pas de nouveaux uniquement l'idée d'un
idéal uniquement un romantique et
merveilleux site et ensuite un moyen de
réponse à des problèmes concrets comme
le fédéralisme c'est plus simple de
gérer les grandes ont géré leurs
problèmes plutôt que de créer un système
centralisé qui imposerait une solution
unique et la démocratie directe est
vraiment un outil de
deux réponses qui sert à corriger
proposer des remèdes à des problèmes au
niveau de la démocratie des eaux de la
responsable de l'organisation tendance
et de l'état sa sanction c'est une
longue histoire
oui alors pourquoi il mais c'est une
longue histoire oui l'une s'est dit sûr
de huit siècles et c'est ça qui plaît à
diffuser que ça qu'ils disent oui
d'accord ils ont mis en place
progressivement pour en arriver là la
démocratie directe en france on n'en est
pas du tout là la structure n'est pas là
selon vous disons que là le système
suisse s'est organisée autour de cinq
consensus dont plusieurs pays se nomme
parfois mais le consensus
justement permet a été créé et non pas
nouveau comme dans l'invention spontanée
mais c'est le résultat logique de cette
démocratie directe qui oblige toutes les
parties prenantes à débat à se mettre
autour de la table à discuter à négocier
et à reconnaître le vote où la décision
qui a été prise c'est là où des la
tradition vous pensez qu'en france et à
trois de position
la culture politique française est
davantage axé sur le groupe virtuel
quand même on voit bien qu'à chaque fois
qu'ils les négociations c'est d'après
conflictuelle qui est bien en avance
n'était pas à sa dimension recherche de
solutions elle viendra peut-être mais
après des durs combats si je puis dire
des tensions assez pudique et là je
pense qu'il ya c'est la grande
différence
ceci dit il ya des moyens qui peuvent
très bien exprimer très expérimentés y
compris en france je crois que c'était
durant la campagne de présidentielle qui
avait débouché sur l'élection des
beignets de macron certains candidats
avaient repris certains idéaux six ans
par exemple le par le biais d'un d'une
récolte de signatures apposées au
parlement français assemblée nationale
de devoir prendre position sur tel ou
tel sujet moi je pense que pour un pays
comme la france il se si elle
s'intéressait à ce type de démocratie
développant celle de la dsi comme
représentative et bien ce genre d'outil
intermédiaire pourrait créer une culture
axée autour de cette démocratie directe
qui nourrit leur rendement de débat
démocratique et qu'il joue si chaque
citoyen à s'intéresser un minimum aux
débats et aux sujets qui sont mis en
discussion
d'ailleurs il existe en france le
référendum d'initiative partagée le rip
qui entre en vigueur en janvier 2015 et
mais il prévoit que 10 % du corps
électoral vote c'est-à-dire 4 7 millions
environ de votants ce qui est totalement
irréalisable en a eu un référendum pour
la nationalisation des aéroports il n'a
obtenu qu'un peu plus d'un million de
votes
donc en fait comparer à la suisse 1
votre pays
avec cent mille signatures minimum en
effet la proportion n'est pas la même et
on n'a pas réussi en france a trouvé
quelque chose qui est à peu près
proportionnée ça c'est la difficulté
c'est qu'il ne faut pas un bon deal à
dieu devienne un obstacle qu'il serait
difficile d'être autour dire je ne veux
pas dans les fêtes et il ne se passe pas
ça mais il ya aussi celles qui parfois
dangereux qu'il pratique en italie et
hongrie qui vient saper le système
suisse mais avec un quorum de
participation obligatoire ce qui est là
aussi
donc je vois pas ce que ça signifie que
toutes les personnes qui ne veut pas
votre compte en réalité alors à titre
personnel c'est contre ce genre d'outil
car là aussi
ou bien on a trouvé ce système là il
faut faire en sorte au contraire que le
plus grand nombre possible de personnes
puissent y participer et que leur avis
sera pris en compte et non pas par des
techniques juridico-administrative
empêché en réalité le peuple s'exprimer
olivier me venir on va marquer une
courte pause on va se retrouver juste
après pour continuer à parler de la
démocratie directe en suisse
[Musique]
de retour dans la grande interview avec
eux olivier meuwly historiens écrivains
suisses qui nous parle depuis lausanne
de la démocratie directe en suisse
démocratie qui fait beaucoup d'envieux
notamment celle et gilet jaune en france
alors nous parlions de ces propositions
si elles recueillent suffisamment de
signatures et bien les citoyens suisses
vont aux urnes quatre fois par an est ce
que vous pouvez nous parler de ce
processus
une fois que le nom de pro natura été
requis ce soit pour un référendum
d'initiative populaire est bien le sujet
et mis au programme des votations on
nous appelle en suisse pour un
référendum c'est assez rapide
une loi a été votée au préalable par les
chambres fédérales contestation non de
certains croquis est dans les quelques
mois qui suivent
et bien la loi est soumise au vote et
tous les suisses et suissesses de 18 ans
et plus peuvent aller s'exprimer pour
les séries populaires c'est un processus
qui est beaucoup plus long car c'est
donc une idée qui vient du peuple qu'il
ya une association quelconque dans la
création d'un groupe de citoyens de
partis politiques aussi parfois qui
utilisent ce moyen pourra intervenir
fortement et pour peser sur le débat
public même des partis gouvernementaux à
droite conservatrice où les socialistes
sont des situations utilisateurs
fréquents de cet outil et l'envoya
pendant un an et demi maximum
eh bien ils peuvent récolter les
signatures requises pour que le sujet
alors soit transmis au gouvernement le
conseil général qui prend position sur
le sujet il peut pour ça c'est rare il
peut être content
c'est souvent le cas mais alors comme je
sais tout à l'heure il peut aussi pour
en faire une contre proposition qui
pourrait alors être aussi soumise au
peuple
et ensuite ce sont les chants générale
qu'ils ont c'est un rossi utilise le
seul le train positions peuvent aussi
amendé corrigé développer une contre
proposition et claire dautherives on
aura en douze objets liés à ce point
soumis
on est là commence tôt pour le faire
donc fossati ville à la campagne de
votation comme on les appelle
et qui sont ces moments la vie politique
suisse beaucoup plus importants que les
campagnes électorales tel car le
parlementaire il a jamais été question
de ce qui met en suisse est vraiment une
démocratie dit compter celui direct à la
fois parlementaires et demi que la
démocratie directe et donc la beauté de
la campagne s'est engagée et souvent
d'ailleurs les politiciens suisses
ils n'ont peut être plus au travail dans
le cadre des votations du compagnon
votation ou là il joue un rôle et pour
les contres et il y avait le débat les
médias publics privés jouent très bien
le jeu il ya donc pour cette faute
personnelle même si certains le
contestent que je pense que
l'information est bonne les la
possibilité de débattre
hamon une élection est extrêmement large
et sécurisé de ce fait ça rend les
citoyens suisses très responsable
beaucoup plus conscients politiquement
il commet elle s'expliquer il ya les
médias j'imagine mais a délivré qui sont
distribués pour bien comprendre la
position
en effet le conseil fédéral distribue
une documentation avec le matériel de
vote a toutes les électrices et
électeurs dans ce matériel
il ya une rotation par le gouvernement
il ya les pro et les contres qui
s'exprime également dans les
contestations par les ordres les autres
sur la façon dont les objets sont
présentés et rendu en général ça se
passe très bien
donc tout citoyen et citoyenne reçoivent
ce matériel ou d'ailleurs se renseigne
et par ce biais là et puis alors il ya
toute la campagne
en effet par les médias les partis
politiques faut aussi leur publicité
certains s'engageront pour d'autres
contre donc on retrouve les conflits
autres partis également autour des
objets de votation
mais avec cette particularité c'est que
à la fin directement suisse c'est ça qui
fait le kaki qui sous-tend le consensus
c'est que l'ebit fois c'est la gauche
qui gagne des fois c'est la droite aux
affaires
pour résumer donc fait recours ça va mal
mais justement quoi ça tient
beaucoup de votes qui ont amené à une
modification de la loi en retrait de loi
quels sont les moments emblématique
justement de ces votations
c'est à dire que j'ai une chute même que
un sujet arrive aux votations signifie
qu'il ya un problème ou bien qu une loi
adoptée par le parlement
s'il est contesté ça monte qui a que
même un doute et s'ouvre les référendums
soient acceptées ça veut dire qu'une loi
votée par les chambres fédérales et
rejeter ce qui oblige les les
partenaires politiques à se remettre
autour de la table et a représenté
quelque chose est souvent le de la
deuxième chose est acceptée et le projet
passe donc sa montre et bien la fois
qu'il ya un sentiment qui était diffus
et qui montre l attention des sujets
fiscaux récemment sous la pression
internationale la suisse a dû revoir son
système fiscal
une loi fédérale a été élaboré dans les
cantons qui sont compétents et nos
communes loire ayral qui chapeaute le
tout est bien là premier projet a été
largement rejetée et de nouvelles
discussions qui ont débouché sur un
nouveau projet qui a alors reconnu un
large consensus dont les partis
politiques et dans la population mais et
pour des initiatives par exemple on a
beaucoup parlé en france ou ailleurs
c'est sur les mines à 4,10 à lévis derek
était acceptée par le peuple
donc ce fameux plus de risques sur les
vaches à cornes qui a failli passer
et là c'est des sujets qui ont qui peut
avoir par apparaître ou trop polémique
ou par la pittoresque mais le fait
qu'ils interviennent qui sont annoncés
ça oblige la population et le monde
politique aaa sovereign du sujet à
l'autre est un exemple est salée il
pourrait pas y avoir de dérive populiste
vous parlez des minarets justement et si
l'accueil des migrants
oui jusqu'où on peut aller dans les la
tentation populiste plus très loin
d'être raciste ouais on peut être est
noire et vide alors c'est vrai que là
leurs proches de de risque doit d'avoir
des votations sur des sujets dits
populiste mais je pense malgré tout que
le meilleur moyen pour lutter contre le
populisme c'est précisément d'en
discuter
de trancher en suisse contrairement à
d'autres pays ces sujets même populiste
qui sont mis sur la table doivent être
discutées ne sont pas amis soudain sous
le boisseau un instant les maîtres côté
on n'en parle plus enfin on fait
semblant que c'est réglé
conçue sinon on peut pas repousser
éternellement le traitement des
problèmes et on voit d'abord tiendra une
fois initiatique sur la peine de mort
qui n'a jamais atteint le nombre de
signatures
je compterai sida par exemple sur
l'avortement non remboursés jusqu'à la
ddt les états possibles soient atteints
sur l'assurance chômage laci paternité
hayatou des conflits des débats mais
tout sujet je dirais et montre qui a un
malaise de la société et qu' il est
urgent que le monde politique sont me
paraît même les sujets qui sont rejetés
laisse toujours des traces
par exemple les grandes réformes de
l'armée suisse à la fin des années 80 m
initiatives pour l'abolition de l'armée
qui avait été rejeté mais avec un score
assez honorable ce qui avait obligé le
conseil général l armée suisse a entamé
les travaux de réforme
donc même un un sujet qui est rejeté et
bien c'est l'occasion on peut progresser
et est ce que ça veut dire également que
les politiques sont plus à l'écouté
parce que si la loi ne convient pas aux
citoyens ils vont contre attaquer
directement avec un référendum
donc tout est un peu régulé finalement
il ya un dialogue constant entre les
politiques et les citoyens en suisse oui
je prouve en effet que cette fameuse
licence que l'on constate souvent et qui
est souvent dénoncée dans les pays qui
ont tous la suisse entre le monde
politique et les citoyennes et citoyens
le peuple en consomment
je pense reçu ce sont aussi les débats
sur ces questions là je vous rassure
mais je pense que ce fossé les mots -
grand parce que justement les outils
démocratie directe permette au peuple de
prendre position à sont assez
importantes et par rapport à même
principe participatif dont on parle
beaucoup aujourd'hui qui est tout à fait
intéressant d'ailleurs à démocratie
directe elles offrent de véritables
procédure qui débouche sur les résultats
et les résultats qui oblige les
différents acteurs
le susten politique comment est on peut
éviter que diverses forces économiques
ou des lobbys s'infiltre dans ses
propositions démocratie directe
s'infiltre au change à l'issue des votes
il s'infiltre pas parce qu'ils y sont je
dirais que le système associatif c'est
très dense
il a précédemment largement le système
des partis politiques
la politique s'est créée par le gré des
grandes associations au 19e siècle et
20e ni de matériels n'ont rien changé à
cet aspect là et c'est vrai que les
référendums d'initiative reçoivent
souvent de soutien ou sont lancés par
les grandes associations parfois
économiques parfois écologique parfois
syndicale parfois dons de citoyens à un
groupe de personnes ici ou là donc je
dirais que l'intégration de l'élément
associatif est inhérent à la hausse si
cette démocratie directe l'accompagnent
le processus est dès lors je dirais que
le risque à mon avis est relativement
d'intervention aux malheureuses et est
limité la mesure où s'est ouvert tout
c'est qui est derrière cette association
telle ou telle votation qui et pour qui
et contre tous assez largement diffusé
après la question du financement
évidemment certaines associations sont
moins riches que d'autres
et là aussi c'est pas forcément un
critère à mon sens et les votations des
fois annoncée par les comptes de
citations citoyens qui n'avaient aucun
moyen financier extraordinaire et qui
ont gagné d'ailleurs à l'arrivée
donc il faut pas d'avoir les surestimer
la question financière mais s'est
ensuite pour cela que souvent ce qui
dans ce référendum l'initiative ou bien
proviennent ou bien recherche l'appui de
nouveaux adhérents d'associations que
danic suisse ou syndicales ou
écologiques ou d'autres en fonction des
objets leur présence mais finalement
c'est aussi un peu son tour comme vous
disiez une fois à gauche une fois la
droite et quelles sont les limites de
cette démocratie directe parce que par
exemple on ne peut pas obtenir le départ
d'un ministre d'un élu donc ça s'arrête
ou jusqu'où peut aller le peuple lui si
c'est bon il ya il est assez clair pour
le système de 2 par rapport à l'effet y
avait déjà pas le site de révocation à
quand on le connaît mais lui mais ça use
révocation qui ont été pratiqués au
10ème siècle mais c'est très rare est
souvent en effet ce système est exclue
parce que pour ne pas déstabiliser la
conduite de l'état
même si vous cassez direct une sorte d
déstabilisation permanente en quelque
sorte et le monde politique se stabilise
à travers cette déstabilisation
qu'apporte la discussion constante et de
politique le canton de genève parle de
réintroduire ce droit de révocation que
vous évoquez dans le cadre de scandales
qui a eu dans la république genevoise
mais c'est un effet mal mais je pourrais
on pourrait très bien imaginer une
initiative populaire de bras par exemple
de monde
la révision de la constitution fédérale
avec l'introduction du droit de
révocation permettant à cent mille
citoyens allaient demander le départ du
conseil fédéral
il faut que tu seras si compliqué dans
le système fédéral c'est d'élection du
gouvernement est assez compliquée mais
qui a deux étages
car c'est deux choses des râles qui
élisent le coup dans le monde on
pourrait imaginer il ya eu des voix une
initiative populaire plusieurs fois
d'ailleurs qui demande l élection du
conseil fédéral par le peuple s'était
refusé à chaque fois mais voilà c'est ça
on pourrait arriver que par la
constitution
on aboutit c'est une révolution parce
que ce serait le cas on peut ensuite du
système électoral du gouvernement
et quels sont les sujets du moment pour
les votations r ce que les suisses sont
très intéressés pour aller aux urnes
parce que vous connaissez le taux
d'abstention en france qui est très
important comment ça se passe en suisse
mais ensuite le taux d'abstention est
plus ou moins élevé il y parle aussi des
rabais faut pas non plus se leurrer jeu
directeur général sont les élections qui
souffrent le plus de l'abstentionnisme
de la population comme je le dis
l'élection c'est important mais ce n'est
pas le seul moyen de montrer son avis la
démocratie helvétique pour les aider les
les votations
c'est très variable tous les sujets
peuvent atteindre 34 en fonction du taux
de retour des deux taux de participation
seront ceux qui participent et nous
pensions qu'ils s'abstiennent le calcul
est vite fait en revanche certains
sujets tueur extrêmement points double
attaque c'est bon j'ai un peu con et
qu'ils ont retraité puisse ordonner
habitants sauviat l'europe par exemple
il y est alarmé liés à ces sujets
fiscaux très intense qui se développe
dans le pays et dont on peut aller à des
taux de 70% de participation 6 donc
c'est vrai l'abstentionnisme est une
réalité mais les gens ne sont pas dupes
8 août a conclu qu'ils seront commentés
un sujet particulièrement presque trimer
violon et bien alors il ya un afflux au
mode qui est assez intéressant
merci olivier meuwly c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de nous avoir
éclairé sur la démocratie directe en
suisse rappelle que vous êtes écrivain
historien suisse spécialiste de
l'histoire des idées et des partis
politiques vous pouvez revoir cette
émission en intégralité sur rtl france
point tv merci de votre fidélité à
bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]